Buon pomeriggio a tutti che emozione Wow
è un onore per me dare il via a questa
edizione di Telex Jesolo che peraltro ha
come tema la passione la mia vita è
fatta di passione io ho vissuto di
passione vivo di passione di passione e
di sogni e queste due parole per me sono
estremamente collegate vicine la
passione ti colpisce e può generare un
sogno e per poi provare a raggiungere
quel sogno devi lavorare con passione
Oggi abbiamo sicuramente tutti una
grandissima opportunità
di crescita ascoltando le esperienze che
verranno condivise su questo palco
però Scusate Cosa vuol dire passione
passione è una parola che deriva dal
latino e vuol dire soffrire
è una sofferenza pensate La passione di
Cristo sicuramente oggi lo interpretiamo
come un qualcosa che
tocca l'animo
e diventa quindi poi il motore che noi
abbiamo per raggiungere i nostri sogni
pensate che quasi si contrappone nel suo
significato iniziale alla parola azione
quando invece poi in realtà se abbiamo
una passione
dobbiamo lavorare per perseguire quel
sogno e quella passione
Ora però vi devo raccontare Quali sono
le mie passioni Qual è la mia passione o
Quali sono le mie passioni
la mia prima passione è stato il volo da
ragazzino
o sono stato colpito travolto
da questo da questa immagine di un
aeroplano e ho detto io Voglio volare e
la prima cosa che ho fatto sono andato
da mio papà alla fine del liceo Mio papà
era come l'amministratore delegato stava
chiuso in sala dove i bussare per
entrare quindi Ho bussato mi ha detto
prego io sono entrato e una volta dentro
Ho detto papà
Ho deciso che dopo il liceo voglio
entrare in Accademia Aeronautica per
diventare un pilota della aeronautica
militare lui mi ha guardato e mi ha
detto Sono molto fiero di questa tua
scelta
dovete parentesi dovete sapere che non
era un grandissimo studente ai tempi
però sappi che
dovrai impegnarti molto di più se
l'impegno che metterai sarà quello che
hai messo fino adesso non potrai
raggiungere questo sogno
Ecco la prima cosa che voglio lasciare è
non date mai retta a chi vi dice non ce
la farete mai non ce la farai mai ma
date retta a chi vi dice Come fare anche
in maniera critica mio papà è stato
critico nei miei confronti però mi ha
dato la soluzione Devi impegnarti devi
sacrificarti devi lavorare duro se vuoi
raggiungere quel sogno
ricordando sempre il principio
fondamentale che il migliore amico non è
quello che ti dice che hai sempre
ragione il miglior collaboratore non è
ragione tu capo e quello che mette anche
i panni della persona che ti vuole bene
e quindi fa lo sforzo in più di dirti
quello che pensa detto questo quello per
me è stato un momento di grandissimo
cambiamento Ho iniziato a lavorare
durissimo a sacrificarmi per raggiungere
Questo obiettivo e ce l'ho fatta sono
dell'Accademia sono diventato un pilota
dell'Aeronautica Militare volato diversi
anni come pilota operativo fatto di
istruttore e poi ha avuto l'onore di
entrare a far parte della pattuglia
acrobatica nazionale le Frecce Tricolori
dove ho passato un importante periodo
della mia vita più di 11 anni dal 98 al
2010 non
potete immaginare quante volte ho volato
qua a Jesolo e portando per altro per la
prima volta
il simbolo della passione secondo me il
cuore che una manovra che insieme alle
frecce ho creato nel 2006 quando ero il
leader ho volato come gregario volato
come leader leader delle frecce la punta
quindi il capo quello che dagli ordini
dai più semplice dei fumi ai più
complessi delle manovre
è quello che ha la responsabilità del
volo sia dal punto di vista estetico sia
dal punto di vista della sicurezza
Quindi quello che garantisce che tutto
si svolga in sicurezza e le Frecce
Tricolori ci tengo a sottolinearlo
evidenziarlo velocemente sono la
pattuglia acrobatica più numerosa del
mondo l'unica che vola con 10 aeroplani
dieci persone di ferro molto grosse e
potenti Grazie che volano attenzione a
due metri l'uno dall'altro
due metri circa
600-650 km/h
le accelerazioni a cui vengono
sottoposti piloti nella terza dimensione
perché l'aeroplano si muove sul piano ma
l'altezza dimensione variano tra i meno
4G ai più 8g se c'è qualche appassionato
di Formula 1 sa che si inizia a parlare
anche di questo ovviamente parliamo di
identità completamente diverse e
soprattutto di direzione di applicazione
delle forze molto diverse e le quota a
cui volano le frecce la più alta Quella
che raggiungono con la manovra sviluppo
verticale più alta e 1.500 metri quella
cui era che a cui sono autorizzate a
volare la più bassa è 15 metri
quindi immaginate che sinergia e che
passione guida queste persone che
condividono un obiettivo unico quello di
rappresentare l'Italia nel mondo dopo
questo sono diventato Addirittura il
comandante delle frecce tricolori che
velocemente Devo purtroppo darvi una
brutta notizia comandante non è più un
pilota non gioca più la partita alla
domenica quando vedete le frecce
tricolori in volo qui a Jesolo non c'è
il comandante a terra però è
l'amministratore delegato dell'azienda
Frecce Tricolori quindi è colui che
gestisce è colui che ha la
responsabilità di
del raggiungimento della missione della
pattuglia acrobatica nazionale che è per
l'appunto come vi ho detto prima
rappresentare il sistema paese spesso
dietro alle missioni delle frecce
tricolori all'estero ci sono motivi o
politico diplomatici o di supporto al
sistema economico industriale
un caso che ho vissuto molto particolare
è stato nel 2009 quando che qualcuno
magari potrebbe anche ricordare la loro
presidente del consiglio decise di
mandare le frecce tricolori in Libia ai
tempi esisteva ancora
un signore che si chiamava Gheddafi
scatenando l'ira dell'opposizione detto
questo una rivolta di una volta arrivati
lì il tutto diventò ancora più difficile
perché questo signore voleva che noi
usassimo i fumi verdi e non Il Tricolore
il fumo verde ai tempi era il colore
della sua bandiera e ovviamente questo
non era possibile è andata bene abbiamo
volato col tricolore perché
era la missione delle frecce tricolori e
questo comunque è stato ancora una volta
un esempio in cui questo reparto questo
gruppo di persone perché nulla si fa da
soli ha dimostrato l'attaccamento la
lealtà e la passione verso questo lavoro
e in questo caso anche verso la propria
nazione Italia
in quel momento io stavo per finire la
mia esperienza come
comandante delle frecce
ma
la mia passione non era poi diventare un
generale o non era neanche magari
seguire la vita del pilota e quindi
diventare un pilota civile avevo altri
sogni che sono maturati nel tempo e mi
si è presentato un'opportunità
incredibile
appena finito il comando con le frecce
ho ricevuto una telefonata era
un'azienda che si chiamava Ferrari che
mi chiedeva se volevo andare a lavorare
per loro quindi io mi sono dimesso e
sono andato a lavorare in Ferrari altro
sogno altra passione altro sacrificio
anche un po' di rischio
I sogni per essere realizzati hanno
bisogno di passione forza sacrificio
lavoro sofferenza probabilmente e anche
una quantità di rischio dove però
rischio
non vuol dire
azzardare saper rischiare vuol dire
studiare prepararsi mitigare i rischi e
lasciare una quota che può essere magari
un problema però oggi ancor di più
stare fermi
È più pericoloso che muoversi e io dico
sempre il rischio più grande che
possiamo correre oggi è Non correre
alcun rischio
quindi ho accettato questa sfida mi sono
dimesso dal posto statale fisso e sono
andato a volare in un'azienda
meravigliosa dove però magari dopo un
paio di settimane potevo già che essere
fuori e invece ho passato un periodo
bellissimo Ho imparato tantissimo Sono
stato sette anni in Ferrari e ho fatto
tre lavori estremamente diversi In
realtà mi hanno proprio usato come
agente di cambiamento Ho lavorato due
anni in Formula 1 seguivo il team
lavoravo direttamente con Stefano
Domenicali potete capire la mia
emozione durante il primo Gran Premio mi
ero appena tolto la tuta di pilota delle
frecce tricolori avevo addosso la tuta
Ferrari col mio nome ricamato sopra e
anche lì la passione che si vive è
estrema è una squadra che vive di
passione
esagero lavoreresti quasi gratis per una
squadra di quel genere lì perché la
passione supera quello che ti possono
dare in qualsiasi modo poi ho lavorato
in risorse umane faccio una parentesi su
questi due anni perché il compito che mi
è stato dato in questi due anni è stato
quello di lavorare alla cultura
aziendale la cultura aziendale il modo
in cui vive una squadra in modo in cui
si confronta scambia opinioni e la prima
cosa che ho fatto è essere leader del
progetto con cui sono stati riscritti la
vision la mission e i valori di quella
azienda e uno dei valori di Ferrari è la
passione
le persone sono guidate dalla passione è
sentito fa parte del Dna di un'azienda
di quel genere poi sono diventato ris
manager E dopo qualche anno anche lì ho
maturato un'altra passione un altro
sogno per cui mi sono licenziato da
Ferrari e ho iniziato a fare altro
adesso
è una storia Quasi incredibile
però lavoro sono amministratore delegato
di un'azienda e sono in consigli di
amministrazione e comitati del mondo
Finanza e assicurativo quindi dagli
aeroplani alla Finanza e
dell'assicurazione un percorso
incredibile dove però io ho sempre
Imparato
mi sono sempre messo in discussione sono
sempre cresciuto Quindi adesso sono
certo che voi vi starete domandando ok
Quindi qual è la tua passione il volo la
Ferrari le macchine
la mia passione Se devo essere sincero è
proprio crescere imparare fare le cose
che non so fare imparare le cose che non
so
E perché questo perché
nella nostra vita è tutto bello non c'è
una cosa più bella di un'altra
Purché sia quello che desideriamo noi
Infatti l'unica cosa che
tutti noi dobbiamo stare attenti è non
far condizionare le nostre passioni e
sogni
dagli altri o dalla società
nella vita ci sono tantissime cose belle
che si possono fare e io mi sono dato
l'obiettivo di vivere più vite possibili
per provare più cose
anche nella coscienza che avete visto Ho
fatto lavori completamente diversi
Sapete cosa ho imparato
il lavoro degli altri è facile solo fino
a quando tocca a te farlo
lì capisci che qualsiasi cosa è
difficile che qualsiasi cosa è comunque
bella e ha un lato appassionante
quindi
La mia preghiera oggi è
e ve lo auguro con te con tutto il cuore
Vi auguro di continuare a sognare sempre
perché i sogni non hanno età né limiti
siamo noi spessissimo il limite a noi
stessi
se avete un sogno bisogna provare nella
coscienza che può essere difficile ma
bisogna provarci assolutamente Ed
arresta le persone che ti aiutano non a
quelle che ti dicono non ce la farai mai
Vi auguro di continuare a sognare Vi
auguro di continuare a coltivare le
vostre passioni e vi auguro
di emozionarvi sempre grazie
Grazie a tutti Buon tutto
[Applauso]